I think that thinking that there is some
deeper reality what is going is probably
going to suffer from the same sort of
issues that would apply to the the one
that you know it's normally taken to be
reality and and I it seems to me in
terms of the impact means there is it I
agree with something it's your
motivation and the sense of yes we
should be scared of a world in which
people freewheel with accounts which are
not thought through and which are
internally incoherent and which don't
work very well for sure we should do
that and in in the current situation I'm
constantly wanting to point to the value
of looking looking to see whether this
account this closure this model this
narrative of the world works and and
pointing out as Donald will say where
it's not working looking for the failure
so I agree with all of that but I also
want to point to what seemed to me is a
structural function of closures which is
that they fail they're not the same
thing as openness and they always fail
whatever the closure is whatever your
account is it will fail including mine
and that is something to understand
about the nature of what it is to think
when we think things we don't arrive we
we have a vehicle to try and do
something and if we start looking at it
more closely it won't work and when we
find it doesn't work we we modify it we
try and add something to it we try and
make it work better we keep on doing
that but we we never the idea that will
arrive seems to me to be the mistake and
indeed the danger because people go to
war over thinking that they've arrived
there's a consensus about this notion of
what works and we try to achieve that
theory or conception of the world or
whatever you want to call it that words
but what decides that whether sub theory
or review works or not it is the world
not us it's not another theory that
decides it's our interface with the
actual world the world we bang your head
against something when we have an
incorrect view of the world and that it
is that that determines what works or
not and surely you should agree with
that well I think this the notion it's
just correct or incorrect I don't think
no it just works no let's talk about
more it's an important shift in the
vocabulary isn't it because the works is
do we find it a way that helps us
achieve our goal but is it correct means
that somebody is wrong and somebody is
right so I'd rather say well which
vocabulary is going to work in this
situation better the will be if we if
you stick to one one way of holding
things you can always support it you can
always find ways to support your view we
all know those people who have sort of
fairly mad views and they'll support
them some of you will think that it's me
but but we can [ __ ] we can find ways to
support those those views we can always
do that
that doesn't solve the problem for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at AI TV
you